man I'll present a wonderful actor and a
loyal friend and member of the Academy
ladies and gentlemen mr. George Murphy
thank you very much Bob each year a
special committee of top men in the
technical crafts is appointed to review
the scientific or technical achievements
of the past year this year the committee
has voted these as the outstanding
technical accomplishments first the
development and application of para
light a new process for set construction
by Victor kachi Leon's ax Maurice Aires
and the Paramount set construction
depart
second a new process for preserving and
flame proofing foliage developed by Nick
Calvin Lewis Witte and the 20th Century
Fox mechanical effects department
honorable mention goes to Marty Martin
Jack Lennon Russell Sherman and the RKO
special effects Department for
developing a new method of simulating
falling snow on motion picture sets and
to AJ Moran and the Warner Brothers
electrical department for a method of
remote control for shutters on motion
picture art by ting equipment as always
the industry is grateful for these
advances which adds skill and speed to
the making of motion pictures